[Musica]
gli algoritmi sono tra noi toccano tutti
i punti delle nostre vite pensate a voi
a noi oggi quante volte abbiamo
utilizzato il nostro smartphone magari
per farci suggerire la strada più veloce
migliore per arrivare qui in questo
incantevole teatro oppure abbiamo
navigato online e un algoritmo ci ha
suggerito quale film guardare o ancora
quale posto visitare nel prossimo
weekend è del tutto naturale utilizzarli
come è altrettanto naturale alimentarli
con i nostri dati ma facciamoci un
attimo
caso tutto questo decidere probabilmente
è derivante dal fatto che prima eravamo
noi a decidere appunto che cosa
l'algoritmo dovesse fare adesso è la
macchina che decide per noi e perché E
beh Probabilmente perché ci rende la
vita più semplice ammettiamolo ci dà la
possibilità di fare più velocemente
Tante attività risparmiando tempo
appunto denaro e persino pensare
e questo è probabilmente dovuto dal
fatto che sta aumentando quella velocità
che c'è tra la capacità di queste
macchine di crescere velocità
esponenziale e dall'altro lato la nostra
capacità di adattarci a questo
cambiamento che è un po' più lenta e
tutto questo quindi fare pensare e
decidere della macchina per
noi ci porterà a diventare più
stupidi voglio provare a rispondere a
questa domanda utilizzando delle trame
le trame delle reti neurali
dell'intelligenza artificiale utilizzate
appunto dle ai e partiamo Questa è la
trama di una rete di tipo convoluzionale
non vi farò lo spiegone tecnico ma
questa rete Può essere utilizzata ad
esempio per fare queste cose clonare la
nostra voce guardate qua voce del nipote
clonata dall'intelligenza artificiale
chiede soldi Nuova truffa per anziani
Oppure ancora truffe telefoniche
intelligenza artificiale può clonare
timbro voce Come proteggersi Oppure
ancora al telefono cos'è la clonazione
della voce generata dall'intelligenza
artificiale perché è un pericolo e come
evitarla con la stessa trama però si può
fare anche questo ovvero l'intelligenza
artificiale ha permesso di creare
l'ultima canzone dei beatus
completarla è proprio Paul McCartney
alla BBC a dichiararlo Stanno
completando l'ultimo pezzo perché John
non c'era più ma con la stessa trama lo
smartphone che statisticamente il 50% di
voi ha in tasca nell'ultimo
aggiornamento è in grado di fare questo
e cioè può dare la voce A chi la sta
perdendo registrando un centinaio di
frasi al vostro smartphone e lui è in
grado di clonar e quindi di farla
utilizzare a quei malati di SLA che
Purtroppo la malattia porterà fargli
perdere la voce però con questo sistema
potranno continuare a fare delle
telefonate magari con i propri cari ma
andiamo avanti ci sono altre trame
Questa è quella ad esempio utilizzata
nel mondo delle reti del Deep Learning
per intenderci son quelli che ad esempio
ci danno la possibilità di comprendere
le somiglianze tra noi e gli attori
famosi la ragazza qui alla mia destra ha
un 65% di Sandra Bullock Wow Oppure
ancora Quest'altra ragazza ha pensato
bene di dare impasto il proprio volto ad
un algoritmo e gli ha restituito una
somiglianza con Nicole
Kidman quella stessa trama è utilizzata
dalla Osaka Metropolitan University
pensate allenata da 67.000 radiografie
addominali ed è in grado di fare due
cose la prima curiosa singolare in
indovinare la nostra età ma la seconda
nel momento in cui l'età non lazecca è
perché ci sta segnalando che
probabilmente siamo affetti da
ipertensione o iperuricemia la trama è
la stessa Ed è la stessa utilizzata
dall' MIT per cercare di prevedere il
cancro ai polmoni Oppure quella che sta
utilizzando per prevedere con 4 anni di
anticipo quello al
seno Questa invece è la trama di una
rete di tipo generativa la generative ai
probabilmente l'avete già sentita
parlare quando avete utilizzato Forse vi
è capitato quel famoso chat che vi
restituisce alla scrittura di un prompt
una risposta Beh si possono fare cose
del genere non solo scrivere ma anche
creare dei video Tom Cruise non ha mai
girato queste scene e Ecco possono
essere utilizzati ad esempio per
completare dei film quando L'attore è
venuto a mancare Oppure ancora magari
girare Anzi creare dei messaggi di
politici per cercare di sviare gli
equilibri tra
stati Ma la stessa rete è quella che ha
consentito al mio amico Giacinto di
parlare tedesco vi assicuro lui non ne
capisce assolutamente nulla e sentite un
po' allora con questo video rappresento
presents Pro kliche intelligen einfach
Cat F piegata semplice è un progetto che
è nato in Italia
ma per comunicare tra popoli magari come
ad esempio quest'altra rete utilizzata
per comunicare tra persone che invece
non possono parlare e quindi noi
scriviamo o parliamo e un avatar invece
con il linguaggio dei segni porta il
nostro messaggio non abbiamo finito ci
sono ancora queste altre due trame
quelle di tipo predittive che ci
consente di capire che cosa succederà
domani Ecco sono utilizzati ad esempio
dall'università di Firenze per cercare
di comprendere Dove si trovano le camere
magmatiche per intenderci è utile
saperlo perché ci danno la possibilità
di sapere l'intensità delle prossime
eruzioni vulcaniche
e queste sono già utilizzate ad esempio
all'Etna Vesuvio Stromboli Campi
Flegrei sempre queste trame sono
utilizzate a ad esempio da Autostrade
per l'Italia le utilizzerà per cercare
di programmare quei noiosissimi lavori
che incontriamo sempre quando andiamo in
vacanza e puntualmente creano degli
ingorghi
e quindi tutte queste trame queste reti
neurali gli algoritmi ed di loro
utilizzi Vogliono farci riflettere sul
fatto che la sfida non è nelle macchine
in sé ma in chi c'è dietro c'è ancora
l'uomo centro che muove i fili e crea
trame e non le macchine perché il
problema non è nella potenza degli
algoritmi nelle loro performance ma in
Chi e come vengono introdotti nelle
nostre società nelle nostre
vite voglio salutarvi prendendo in
prestito le parole di un personaggio dei
fumetti zio ben lo zio di Peter Parker
alias spider-man che A proposito di
poteri recitava più o meno così
l'intelligenza artificiale sta
dimostrando di avere un grande potere sa
a noi utilizzarla con grande
responsabilità
[Applauso]
Grazie